hello welcome to breakthroughs from
science mission I am sadashiva pie I am
going to discuss couple of breakthrough
papers published in the week of July
seventh let's start first we will
discuss a paper published by soon
kuriyama in journal of cell biology on
the role of LP a receptor to on cancer
metastasis and embryo development why is
this paper so important collective cell
migration and epithelial-mesenchymal
transition are important during cancer
metastasis and embryo development
authors demonstrate that Proteus
activated receptor 2 plays a role in CCM
and EMT they also show that part 2 ads
were NCAT heading to enhance EMT and
cesium let's look at the data utters
demonstrate LP a receptor 2 signaling is
required for in vivo gene opus neural
crest migration blocking of LP a
receptor to using anti-sense morpholino
impaired NC migration in vivo the
inhibition of NC migration by LP a
receptor to anti-sense was rescued by
overexpression of an mrna encoding
full-length LP a receptor 2 but not by
non phosphorylate able form of the
receptor indicating the phosphorylation
of the receptor is required also in
invasion assay will be a receptor 2 and
essence injected cells consistently
stalled at the entrance or in the first
half of the tunnels tester which
suggests that LPR to anti senses had a
low plasticity authors also showed that
neural crest cells acquire fluid like
behavior that helps them pass through
narrow channels while inhibition of this
phase transition by but blocking LP a
receptor 2 makes us cluster to solid to
pass authors looked at potential changes
in cell-cell junction composition to
understand the mechanism LP a receptor 2
deficient cells showed stronger eniko
Darren straining at the cell-cell
Junction
then in control cells however there was
no changes in mrna our total protein
levels of these molecules which suggests
a role for certain regulation at the
level of spatial distribution of
cell-cell addition complexes evaluation
of n-cadherin endocytosis form that in
kettering was seen in intracellular
vesicles whereas LP a receptor knockout
cells had a strong accumulation of pen
Kieran in the cell membranes cells
expressing activated form of rab5 a
well-known promoter of endocytosis was
sufficient to rescue the effects of LP a
receptor to knock out an uncaring
internalization in cell dispersion assay
authors found that neural crest cells
injected with the control normally break
away a single cells whereas LP a
receptor to anti sentence failed to do
so dispersion defects could be rescued
by LP a receptor to anti cells cells by
lowering calcium blocking and katherine
expression reducing n-cadherin binding
in trance with a blocking antibody or
increasing endocytosis with an activated
rab5 others also show both in vitro and
in vivo cell migration assay that
inhibition of n-cadherin or activation
of n-cadherin endocytosis in LP a
receptor 2 deficient mice is sufficient
to restore plasticity and an analysis of
neural crest migration after inhibition
of n-cadherin using morpholino
overexpression of division contrast
lacking the cytoplasmic domain and a
ketamine binding domain demonstrate that
the importance of n-cadherin for
collective cell migration in vivo others
also show a model to demonstrate the
role of n-cadherin in CCM so this paper
provides proof for self Lester migration
in the presence of LP a receptor to
and show the importance of n-cadherin in
the process next let us look into a
paper published by locked ocean and
colleagues in science authors
demonstrate that merger is the Philip is
required for peptidoglycan biosynthesis
why is this paper so important
understanding bacterial cell wall is
crucial for the development of targets
for new antibiotics identity of lipids
is a necessary for the bacterial wall
integration is controversial authors
demonstrate that merger is indeed a flip
ace lipid two is a disaccharide
pentapeptide that is synthesized at the
cytoplasmic leaflet of the inner
membrane lipid two must be flipped
across the membrane for cell wall
synthesis authors developed an essay for
the flippies activity toxin colchicine
em call em when added to ecoli is
translocated into the periplasm where it
please lipid to when peptidoglycan is
labeled with the tritium for its unique
amino acid labeled products will be
released into the water fraction if flip
ace works inside the cell in the
presence of call em and lipid fraction
was reduced mts es that neutralizes
cysteine in the protein by itself did
not have much effect with merge a
wild-type then did not have any cysteine
but in the presence of mutant emerged a
significantly less water soluble
fraction and more lipid fraction was
seen indicating merge a easy flip paste
the result is further confirmed by the
growth of the cells which is blocked by
M tses in the mutant while
supplementation of merge a restores
growth spero class without outer
membrane provided call em with direct
access to flip
lipid two in the absence of empty SES
call em treatment of wild-type or mutant
spider plus reduce the amount of label
in the lipid fraction indicating that
lipid to was actively flipped and thus
cleaved by call em although mt SES did
not affect call him activity on while
types feed of plus it's completely
abolished lipid to processing by call em
in mutant cruiser class moreover lysis
of mts cs3 Ted mutant spear applause
restored lipid to processing indicating
that the intact I am impeded the axis of
column to lipid to thus merger
affiliates to act as a lipid to flip ace
and could be a target for new
antibiotics thanks for watching science
breakthroughs from science mission